[Musique]
la désinformation c'est possible d'en
rire tout en prenant cette problématique
très au sérieux jean rené dufort pierre
brassard simon olivier fecteau et
olivier niquet nous ont d'ailleurs déjà
fait part de leurs réflexions à ce sujet
ou tour cette semaine que l'humoriste do
it et de venir faire son tour à notre
émission présent sur plusieurs
plateformes pour contribuer au combat
contre la désinformation
il admet d'emblée être inquiet face à la
polarisation et aux dérapages qu'il
constate sur les réseaux sociaux
oui des bons jours très content d'être
revoir des critères et c'est ça plus en
plus de voiles et je me disais oui tu es
vraiment un intérêt marqué pour la
question la désinformation j'imagine que
ça s'est développé dans le temps mais sa
part d'où cet intérêt au juste
peut-être que je passe trop de temps sur
internet peut-être que je suis trop
exposé à la désinformation c'est pour ça
que peut-être que je suis par virginia
par rapport à ça inquiète je trouve que
ça s'amplifie avec les années donc j'ai
de plus en plus inquiète le mien de
popularité semaine et fait ce qu'on
croit une infirmation parce qu'un grand
nombre de gens là considère elle aussi
c'était fou quelques le raid jeudi où il
leur a enlevé d'internât points
nécessaires mais donc c'est ça qui te
fait participer au projet des pistes et
la désinfo c5 est au coeur de sa
démarche oui bon on m'a approché parce
que j'avais visiblement déjà cet intérêt
sur les réseaux sociaux jeux dans monde
a mis en oeuvre dans mes blagues on
voyait que j'aimais ce genre de sujets
là donc on m'a approché parce qu'on
pensait que mettre un peu d'humour dans
ça aiderait à ce que c'est cap sur le
soient bien reçus partager et cetera
elle moi je suis comme je dis je suis
fan de vérité où j'aspire non j'aspire à
la sagesse j'aspire à être à connaître
des choses pis
bien la baisse et des espèces de trier
des embûches c'est comme un saut
obstacle pour acquérir des bonnes
connaissances et puis ils sont là pour
tout le monde son lob que soit le biais
de confirmation aller chercher les
informations qui nous plaisent à nous il
ya plein de billets on les a tous après
ça en apprenant l'existence de ces
biello penser du cas là dessus mais on
arrive des fois à contrer ses réflexes
lautier apprendre à faire attention à
soi même à nos informations fait que
c'est pour ça moi c'est vraiment sa part
d'une volonté d'être meilleur
mais onze buts je le disais tantôt au
fait qu'on réagit souvent sur le coup de
l'émotion moi c'est ce que je constate
ce qui est au coeur du problème des
réactions émotives à des phénomènes
complexes qui nous dépasse on cherche
des repères tout voit maintenant dans ce
que tu dis sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup non mais oui je le vois
puisqu'en personnes partagent certains
trucs je suis en mesure d fois de
comprendre pourquoi le fait aimer à
cause de ses biens lotis on les regarde
on fait comme on est tombé dans un piège
on voit les gens autour de nous tomber
dans ce piège les réseaux sociaux sont
un exemple flagrant parce que ça va plus
on va vite plus on a de chance de tomber
dans ce piège la première personne qui
va partager une information souvent vous
ramassez les gemmes et les partageant
premier fait qu'on il ya beaucoup
d'incitatifs à le faire ça nous fait
faire des erreurs et on ramasse des
gemmes mais aussi beaucoup de haine
parfois c'est le cas avec nous et au
directeur disons que c'est pas toujours
des messages d'amour qu'on reçoit est ce
que ta petite expérience aussi à ce
chapitre la 3g oui ben oui évidemment
parce que je me prononce puis je mets de
la 20 min mes valeurs mes opinions sur
les réseaux sociaux fait que tout le
monde subit un peu la même chose en ce
moment il ya un niveau normal de
désaccords sur des réseaux sociaux avec
lequel je vis très bien aussi je le
comprends il n'y a pas que je pense que
j'étais je me sente investi d'une
mission un peu plus grande que ce que
j'étais en mesure de faire maintenant je
reconnais que je suis un humoriste des
fois je fais comme je vous laisse aux
journalistes faire certaines choses puis
moi je prends un peu de recul je fais
comment quelques jetons humoristes ne
faut pas trop se prendre au sérieux
notre attention et notre esprit critique
ne sont pas à leur meilleur quant au
surf sur facebook la plupart du temps on
est loch pour du verdissement des
postures us déclaré donald trump un
petit pénis
dans le contexte la désinfo
l'utilisation du mot comme outil pour
lutter contre la désinformation
qu'est-ce que tu en fais toi non moi je
change d'opinion sur la charge des îles
souvent je suis un peu je pense que j'ai
un peu trop 1 me sur un piédestal
l'humour dans ces dernières années j'ai
pensé que ça pouvait être solutionnée
tout ça peut être bien c'est pas bon
toujours mais ça pue ça peut être bien
moi j'essaie j'essaie d'être le moins
polarisant j'essaie de faire un humour
rassembleur dans la mesure du possible
mais j'en échappe puis on est dans une
période où les gens pardonne moins ils
se souviennent moi je me fais souvent
dire tu fais juste des blagues sur nous
tu décroches très juste des blagues là
dessus je leur dit des fois comme un
veau regarde et regarde actuellement
combien blague j'ai fait là-dessus versé
sur d'autres choses beaucoup plus
équilibrée qui pensent mais ils s'en
souviennent pas mais il ya des blagues
des fois que je m'en veux
arriver il faut je fais comme par
exemple le mois dernier on a vécu on a
vécu trois semaines et quelques jours de
d'un convoi qui était à ottawa ça
prenait tellement d' espace médiatique
forcément c'était quand même matière à
humour moi j'en ai fait des blagues
là-dessus et c'est vrai qu'en effet
exotisme année je me savais dès fois il
m'a emmené une très très bonne ni trêve
comme celle là j'aurai beaucoup de
gemmes et drôme et c'est vrai que c'est
la 17ème à 22 jours c'est comme si
beaucoup d'excès des fois je fais
comment guertin peu mais justement du
évoque le convoi des camionneurs ça a
été enlevé au décryptage tout un vecteur
de désinformation n'y avait pas que ça
mais on avait
observé en tant que citoyen en tant
qu'humoriste un mélange des deux comment
tu réagis stevenson au début j'ai sauté
j'ai sauté à pieds joints puis je me
suis fait j'ai fait de l'humour là
dessus pas personnellement sur les gens
mais sur ce qui me paraissait le plus
grossier le plus caricatural du
mouvement des choses comme ça puis un
moment donné où je me suis rendu compte
que le discours est
je suis plus certain cij a aidé la cause
de faire encore des blagues parce que ce
groupe là c'est tellement senti attaqué
tellement senti un braquage médiatique
politique l'humoriste et les réseaux
sociaux contre eux que la moindre petite
pointe que je faisais qui en temps
normal je pense mériter un sourire
s'était rendu il était rendu très
sensible c'est là qu'on réalise des fois
que le contexte social rano chose
difficile parce que c'est l'accumulation
moi des fois je me dis ben achour une
blague une seule aujourd'hui mary c'est
la 22e qui voit pas ce qu'il ya plein de
gens qui ont fait des blagues sur eux et
qu'ils nous mettent tous dans le même
panier puis en moi je suis la goutte qui
fait déborder le vase philippe est leur
coach compte - mais je comprends un peu
ils ont tellement leur idée de nous on
est tellement en du pain tueries comme
l'ennemi que ça peut rien de plus de
plus de courroie de communication avec
eux que je sais pas quoi faire
c'est très envahissant qu'on est sur les
réseaux sociaux toutes ces affaires là
ça nous envahir c'est surprenant comment
deux trois semaines après on se rend
compte qu'on parle plus de type notre
beau frère on y parle d'autre chose
puisse y voir des barbecues cet été
autour de la piscine c'est pas la fin du
monde non plus je pense qu'il faut faire
attention aussi mais somme toute les
jambes moi je le dis je les rencontre il
faut toujours faire des spectacles avec
madame qui amène son conjoint qui
m'aiment pas naturellement mais doit
l'amener qui vient voir qu'après dehors
d'une fois je me poserai toutes les
blagues mais le côté drôle puis je me
suis amusé des gens sur des bonnes
personnes les gens sont dans la vraie
vie les à son geste ne l'oublions pas
aller allons-y avec la bienveillance
merci beaucoup lutté pour si une
prochaine